c'est l'un des événements les plus
attendus de 2021
déjà reportée d'un an les jeux
olympiques de tokyo sont toujours prévus
entre le 23 juillet et le 8 août
prochain
mais face à la forte remontée des cas de
covin au japon depuis le début de
l'année les rumeurs d'annulation de ces
jeux reviennent avec insistance
selon le quotidien britannique the times
le gouvernement nippon aurait
secrètement acter cette annulation
une information démentie par le premier
ministre liu xin et sugar en ce qui
concerne les jeux de tokyo ce sera le
symbole d'une humanité qui surmonte le
nouveau coronavirus est une opportunité
pour nous de montrer au monde comment le
japon s'est reconstruit depuis la
terrible catastrophe de fukushima nous
serons prêts pour le prémunir du virus
nous sommes déterminés à travailler en
étroite collaboration avec la métropole
de tokyo
le comité d'organisation des géo et le
cio pour réaliser des jeux olympiques
sûr et sécurisé tokyo 2021 confirmé les
organisateurs se concentre sur les
conditions dans lesquelles ces jeux
pourront se dérouler la présence du
public est au coeur de toutes les
interrogations
il y a deux choses a décidé la première
c'est de savoir si nous allons
accueillir des spectateurs venus de
l'étranger et sur ce point la politique
du gouvernement concernant l'entrée sur
le territoire est primordial la deuxième
concerne les conditions de la capacité
d'accueil du public sur les sites
olympiques qu'il soit étranger ou
résidents japonais
pourra-t-on remplir les stades où
faudra-t-il établir des restrictions
dans la capitale nippone l'arrivée des
supporters venus du monde entier
inquiète la population les tokyoïtes
sont partagés sur la tenue même de ces
jo l'été prochain je me demande s'il ne
serait pas mieux de décaler l'ensemble
du planning des jeux de quatre ans on
aurait le japon dans quatre ans et ainsi
de suite
ça n'aurait pas du tout sens que les
jeux se tiennent sans spectateurs les
athlètes tirent leur courage et leur
force des acclamations du public pour
donner le meilleur d'eux mêmes c'est ça
les jeux olympiques
pour être honnête ça me paraît vraiment
difficile vu la situation actuelle
j'aimerais vraiment que les jeux aient
lieu surtout quand on pense aux athlètes
mais dans un contexte où les
déplacements internationaux sont
compliquées je ne pense pas que ce soit
possible
ça va se jouer au cours des prochains
mois selon l'évolution de la situation
l'idée d'un nouveau report fait aussi
son chemin chez les sportifs sur twitter
l'ancien rameur britannique et champion
olympique se remarque youpine cents
propose de décaler ces olympiades
il milite pour que tokyo soit ville hôte
en 2024 paris en 2028 et los angeles en
mais l'idée semble irréaliste du fait de
son coût le report des jo de 2020 à 2021
a déjà fortement alourdi la facture pour
les organisateurs au total plus de 13
milliards de dollars ont été déboursés
par le japon faisant de ces jeux de
tokyo
les plus chers de l'histoire des jo
d'été